hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast impact of next-generation
sequencing on quizzes precision medicine
presented by Gary Rose PhD a
distinguished scientist at Illumina Inc
I am Kristin production teal lab Ruth
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
Ruth lab versus the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
and if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your credit
now please join me in welcoming dr. Gary
shows I will now turn the presentation
over to him
thank you very much it's great to be
here and I'm want to thank Lab Rhodes
for inviting me to give a presentation
so my name is Gary sure--the I am a vice
president in our product development
group here at Illumina and I've been
working in the field of next-generation
sequencing for just over 12 years now I
was part of the company called celexa
that Illumina acquired 10 years ago and
which got Illumina into the field of
next-generation sequencing and so this
is actually kind of a been a momentous
year for us we celebrate our 10 year
anniversary of the acquisition of Celexa
by Illumina and so it has reminded us
it's kind of fun to look back on the
past 10 years and so the first few
slides I have talked about our
technology and the 10 years of
sequencing innovation that at Illumina
we have driven in our product
development group and for those of you
familiar with our platforms you probably
remember the genome analyzer which we we
launched about 10 years ago followed by
the high seek 2000 which really a huge
increase in output and then the high
seek 2000 was iterated into the 2500 and
the high seek x10 system which brought
on board pattern flow cells it was
really the system that enabled the
thousand-dollar genome in the 2014
timeframe and during that time we also
were working on much smaller benchtop
sort of desktop sort of instruments like
the my seek the next seek in the mini
seek and you can see listed below all
the types of technology breakthroughs
that we have had over the years over the
last decade that have enabled us to
continue to create better faster cheaper
systems in a way that we can drive down
the cost of DNA sequencing significantly
that's shown on this this plot here so
if you if you look at this plot this is
comparing the cost of genome sequencing
sequencing an entire human genome the
cost of sequencing and you can see that
in about 2007 it was still several
million dollars to sequence a genome and
when we launched the genome analyzer in
2007
2008 we were able to bring that cost
down to hundreds of thousands of dollars
which is a significant drop then when we
launched the high seek 2000 system in
around 2010 we brought it down into the
tens of thousands of dollars and we
iterated the heizak 2000 system over the
last four five six seven years and now
basically on the high seek 2000 are the
high seek X system the x10 platform you
can actually get down to thousand dollar
genome prices so this is several orders
of magnitude drop in in sequencing price
over the last ten years and what that
has led to is the the world has sequence
a lot more genomes because of that
because it's a lot less expensive so if
we think back to ten years ago there
literally were just two or three genomes
that had ever been done in the very
first genome was Craig Venters genome
that was done using capillary
electrophoresis in the early 2000s the
454 platform generated Jim Watson's
genome for about two million dollars in
2007 there were several genomes done on
the original GA and GA too and you can
see the price dropping as we as we moved
into the into the 2000s in the hi-c 2000
system so you can see that it's down to
about ten thousand dollar genome and by
this point there are thousands of
genomes done but still not an enormous
amount that we we see today by most
estimates we believe that in 2017 there
will be upwards of a million genome
sequenced using our technology and so
another kind of interesting thing to
look at is the is the throughput of our
high-throughput systems in terms of the
amount of data that each system can
generate and I've made this this sort of
diagram here showing the GA - in 2008
generated about four Giga bases of data
so that's four billion base pairs of
sequence information every basically in
about a week it took to run that
instrument to generate that much data
and that was a lot of data in the day
that this is this was back in the day
when genome centers wouldn't even
generate that much data in a month from
the entire center and so this was a this
was a huge breakthrough in sequencing
and as we just talked about the cost and
if you think about it in terms of hours
per gigabase it took 42 hours to
generate 1 billion base pairs of
sequence information which as I said in
10 years ago that was really really
impressive then when we launched the
high seek 2000 system in 2010 you can
see that the throughput went up
significantly and that at the runtime
stayed about the same so dinner was
about an hour per gigabase and then what
followed then was the hi-c tech system
where we had optimized the hi-c system
to generate much higher throughput and
much less runtime now we're down to two
point four minutes per gigabase and then
finally what I'm going to talk about
today and the first half of my talk is
our latest system which is called the
Nova seek and I'm going to describe this
system in detail and this system is
another sort of quantum leap in terms of
how much data we can generate and also
the runtime and we've dropped the time
per gigabase down to 40 seconds per
gigabyte so this is what I'm going to
talk about in the first half of the talk
is the Nova seeks area the second half
of the talk I'll talk about some
specific applications related to
precision medicine especially cancer so
I want to introduce the Nova six series
we launched this system earlier this
year we have actually been shipping them
and is starting in March and if you
follow Illumina you know that we've
we've actually had quite a lot of
interest in this instrument and quite a
lot of orders as we announced at our at
our recent earnings call a couple weeks
ago but I want to give you a little bit
of technical background on this system
it's a really a breakthrough system a
very scalable platform very flexible
very streamlined and just like the high
seek system took us from hundreds of
thousands of dollars per genome down to
the thousand dollar genome this system
is starting at the sub $1,000 genome and
we think this platform
this system is going to be able to drive
us down to the hundred dollar genome in
the next few years so the Nova system is
actually sold in two different
configurations a that we call it the
five thousand and the six thousand the
only difference between these two is
that the five thousand holds a single
flow cell the six thousand holds two
flow cells also in terms of the flow
cell availability for each is little
slightly different obviously the five
thousand a little bit less expensive but
the main the main thing I want to talk
about today are the four types of flow
cells that we have right now we have
launched with just this flow so if you
look here in this corner you can see the
that the names of the flow cells up here
s1 s2 s3 and s4 those nomenclature is
sort of our naming convention for these
flow cells in each flow cell has this
sort of output a half a terabyte so
that's 500 gigabases one tera base to
tera base and three tera base so that's
three thousand Giga bases of data from
each flow cell so the Nova 66,000 system
for instance can run two flow cells at a
time each one producing three Tara bases
of data and if we look at the output of
this and a little bit more detail you
can see that we have over here on the
left-hand side of the screen you can see
the flow cells types over here and then
you can see the sort of cycle
configurations here so if you look at
the flow cell types s1 through s4 and
the cycle configurations 100 cycle 2
under cycle 3 other cycle you can see
the range of outputs that we get here in
the middle in terms of how many how many
reads we can get in this column or how
many Giga bases of data we can get here
in the in this section and so this
allows you to go from 167 Giga bases of
data using a hundred cycle kit all the
way up to 3,000 Giga bases of data using
the 300 cycle kit and a range of reads
from 1.6 billion up to 10 billion so
quite a lot of flexibility across these
various flow cells and so we'll talk
about how we we engineered that now we
built this system as we go through the
talk so I like to look at some of the
enabling technology that's built into
the system and one of the key things
about this system is that it is
completely different than our high seek
platform it's a completely reimagined
re-engineered sort of from the ground up
new technology and so the high seek 2000
2500 3000 4000 and hi-c HIC DX systems
are essentially the state-of-the-art
genome sequences today all the genomes
that are going to be done last year and
this year mostly going to be done on the
high seek X system that are that have
been out there for a couple of years
those those systems generate about 16
GM's worth of data every three days or
so
the Nova seek is completely reimagined
where we've taken the high seek
architecture the imaging module the
fluidics modules that are built into the
instrument and also into the ceebot
system and also the computer and we've
combined them all into one
floor-standing unit whereas the high
seek sits on a bench these these
instruments are floor-standing
they include a very powerful compute
engine really nice integrated fluidics
and a very powerful imaging module so
the key technology enablers from from
this system which as I mentioned is sort
of redesigned from the ground up
we've designed completely new high
density flow cells we have along with
that come up with an entirely new
surface chemistry to increase the
signal-to-noise new superior very fast
imaging that's one of the keys to this
system and like I said it includes a
really quite powerful built-in computer
that does a lot of data management
primary analysis our RTA real-time
analysis software is eight times faster
than the previous instruments and we've
reformulated the chemistry that that
that does our SBS chemistry as we
calling
so one of the key things to this new
system is the pattern new pattern flow
cell so if you look at our flow cells in
the past for the high seek and the high
seek X system you see there they're
relatively a lot smaller than the Novus
flow cells and so there's a lot less
surface area and also we use this
patterning technology where we put
little Wells into the surface of the
flow cell and you can see that we are
are packing the Wells in slightly
tighter and slightly smaller Wells as
well and so if you look at kind of the
amount of surface area we're looking at
plus the tighter pinch and smaller
smaller Wells we can actually put quite
a bit higher density of information into
the same sort of square millimeter and
then we have a lot more square
millimeters to scan so we could overall
generate quite a lot of output the thing
about this system that is amazing is
that it can scan this large area which
is obviously much larger than this
actually faster than we would scan this
area in on the older systems so this
this shows the clustering chemistry this
system also does all onboard clustering
and if you've ever used our previous
systems you know some of the some of the
desktop ones do on board clustering but
the high seek X and high seek system use
a see bot so we no longer need no longer
need this and we've also worked on the
on the formulations and configurations
of these of these protocols to make
everything a lot faster than it was on
the high CG X system this is a what we
call a two channel chemistry channel 2
channel SBS chemistry and so this is an
evolution of our chemistry that we
started on the next seek several years
ago Mexico into chemistry we actually
use a very similar chemistry on the mini
seek system and so this nova seek
version of this chemistry is probably
our V 4 V 5 of this sort of chemistry
and are in our
in our total portfolio and it's a it's
an interesting situation where we
actually just read to two wavelengths
agreeing in a read and by the
configuration of the dyes we can
actually deconvolution using two
channels and this has shown to give very
very high quality data on all of our
other systems and so far everything that
we've seen off the Nova see looks like
it's also going to be extremely high
quality off of the Nova seek system the
thing about the Nova seek system is that
even though this flow cell is much
larger and has many more spots in it
more more wells if you will the scan
time and run time is actually decreased
almost in half so whereas the high seek
X will do sixteen genomes in about you
know that's three days three plus days
the the Nova seek system can do up to 48
genomes in less than two days so that's
a significant increase in throughput in
terms of ease of use one thing that we
do with all of our latest systems is
that instead of using the way that we
did it in high seek where we use these
trays with many different bottles that
the users have to load in sort of keep
track of make sure they were in the
correct spot for all of these 20
different reagents in the Nova system
all these reagents are built into these
cartridges and so essentially it's just
a matter of loading the three cartridges
loading your sample into one of the
ports here in this cartridge and then
loading the flow cell and then pressing
go so it's much much easier to use all
of our consumables have RFID tracking on
them so that the instrument knows
exactly which instruments it's been used
or what consumables that has been using
what experiment is being done what even
samples are on the flow cell can be sort
of set up in your account before you
start the run the other key to our this
system is that we have really really
much much better optics in this system
than we ever had were able to put into
the high seek systems and so we have a
you know sub pixel geometric distortion
a very very nice nanometer scale laser
based focused tracking and diffraction
limited performance across the full
field of view and you might not be able
to see this in this in this image but
this is one of the fiducials on the that
we put on our flow so so that you can
see things and if you look at the the
high seek image X image here if you look
very carefully it's actually quite
distorted and blurry relative to the
same sample or the same flow cell put on
to the Nova seek imaging system and you
can see that we get really nice
resolution and really even no distortion
across either from side to side or top
to bottom of the flow cell so as I
mentioned that this sim is really fast
in terms of its throughput this is
another way of looking at kind of a
comparison I was doing at the beginning
sort of minutes per gigabyte this is
actually Giga bases per hour and if you
compare the Nova stick 6000 system to
the current state-of-the-art genome
sequencer the high seek X platform you
can see this is a four to five times
faster in terms of Giga bases per hour
in terms of throughput per hour so I
just want to show some little bit of
actual data from these instruments and
we do think these instruments are going
to do a lot of human genomes in the
future and so I wanted to show this data
this is data that we generated during
our beta testing of this instrument
internally and this was using an s2 flow
cell that is specked out at one tera
base you can see we're getting one point
two six Tara bases of data the clustered
passing filter numbers the read one to
thirty members read two to thirty
numbers are very good the error rates
average error rates over the two by 150
base reads are very good and actually
this data is available this this project
in particular is available in our base
base sequence of and I'll show you a
little bit more about that in a second
but just to make a note this was a true
Sikh PCR free 450
insert library using na12878 standard
sample and two by 150 with dual indexing
it was a six library sort of pooled pool
there's so run together in the
instrument this is a little bit more
detailed we also ran the same set of
libraries on high seek X and so we're
comparing the data in terms of where we
down sampled them to very similar levels
we could look at the percent align you
can see they're very very similar across
the two platforms keep in mind that the
high seed X system is essentially the
state-of-the-art system today for doing
human genome sequencing the Nova seek is
comparing quite well in all the major
overall metrics and this just shows
where you can go if you go and if you
have an account in base base or if you
want to sign up for one just go to base
base and the Illumina x' sequence
cloud-based computing environment and if
you go there and go to the area called
public data you can find some Nova seek
data I think actually now there's even
more data up there than I'm showing here
but this particular Human Genome Project
that I was just talking about is
actually in in the cloud and you can
look at all the analysis we've done and
also download the reads yourself and
analyze them yourself if you're
interested one new announcement that we
just started started talking about
relatives of Nova seek in the last few
weeks is a way to individually address
all the lanes when we launched the
system in January and when we started
talking to customers about in January
and February one of the biggest concerns
was the fact that these flow cells are
so huge and they can do so many
different samples so human genomes might
not be that big of a challenge that we
basically twenty-four genomes per s4
flow cell but if you start doing RNA
seek or exomes or or especially anything
below that you're going to want to
sequence you know maybe a hundred sample
hundreds of samples per flow cell on
this kind of with this kind of a
throughput so what we what what we
originally designed the system is that
it has one loading port where one sample
pool would be spread out across the
whole flow cell and what we've decided
to enable is kind of a way to
individually address the lanes on the
Nova cig flow cell so here's a here's a
picture of what this will look like
it'll be a essentially a device that you
can preload your samples into the flow
cell in individual lanes you can see
that this s4 flow cell actually has four
individual lanes across it right and so
this will allow you to put four
different pools of samples onto one s4
flow zone so just to do the math for you
if we have say up to 96 exomes or 96 RNA
seek samples with unique dual indexes
well that's that's another key advance
that we're coming up with is we're going
to have new index adapters coming out
over the summer as well that will have
24 and then eventually 96 unique dual
indexes these will these will allow you
to take advantage of each lane which
will have about 750 Giga bases of data
and so if you were doing say 96 exomes
that would give you 7.8 Giga bases of
data per exome or if you're doing RNA
seek that would give you 26 million
reads per sample for 96 Plex so you
could put like exomes in lane 1 RNA
seeking lanes 2 and 3 and maybe some
genomes in lane 4 that's that's would
give you the flexibility to sort of use
all that all that sequencing power and
be able to subdivide the flow so into
for addressable lanes so now that we
have the the Nova system this is kind of
our forward-looking view of our
portfolio we're at the high end we have
Nova seek which is you know can put out
just enormous amounts of data and at the
low end we have our sort of baby
sequencer called mini seek it actually
puts up it's pretty impressive little
instrument on its own in fact if you
look back to the GA 2 that I was talking
about this little baby sequencer that we
have now is actually more powerful than
the genome analyzer was eight or nine
years ago so this is our portfolio from
bench top to floor standing instruments
that can do panels all the way up to
full genomes and so the next part of the
talk I'm actually going to talk about
applications that principally run on
these smaller instruments mini seek my
seek and Mexique so these are targeted
sequencing solutions for the oncology
space so I'm going to talk about
I picked a just a handful of new and
interesting cancer related tools that we
have developed to share with you some of
the details today so when you talk about
using NGS in cancer oftentimes people
want to look at panels of cancer drivers
genes that are involved in cancer and I
want to be able to study you know normal
or germline tissue and look for changes
and tumors and response and recurrence
and so we have a whole suite of targeted
assays actually and you can see the
sample types from blood to FFPE this
this is FFPE blocks or blood or bone
marrow is also a commonly used sample
type in particular I want to focus on
these three panels truesight tumor 15 to
site 2 or 170 and the true site RNA
fusion these are all different kits with
different application areas and and and
different workflows as well so I want to
introduce you to these three targeted
panel assays first one I want to talk
about is true site RNA fusion this is an
enrichment based panel to study
essentially gene fusions in RNA so the
the challenge was dealt with with using
RNA seek to study known fusions is that
in order to see a fusion so here's a
here's a fusion between these two genes
a cap 9 and b-raf if you look at
the coverage across the entire gene you
can see that the the yellow half of the
gene which is a cap of nine there's lots
of reads covering it and the b-raf side
over here there's also lots of reads but
really the only reads that give you
information about the sort of fusion
itself are the gene or the reads that
fall right along the junction here in
the transcript and so what we've
developed is a way to target targeted
panels that we can sort of been rich for
reads that are around those Junction
areas and essentially what we do is we
do what looks like two halves of a prep
where the first half is essentially a
library preparation where you start with
relatively small amounts of RNA and the
RNA can be FFPE as well and we make a a
stranded total RNA protocol total RNA
library then we take that library here
and put it through an enrichment method
where we used oligos that are targeted
to the genes of interest to capture them
and essentially wash away all the genes
that we're not that interested in in a
way do a focused cancer study on just
the genes of interest and so for
instance in this fusion panel we have
we're targeting 507 of the roughly
23,000 genes in the human genome
so these are genes that are we know are
involved in in fusion events in cancer
and so this is way to kind of study
those genes directly this this assay
actually gives very robust performance
even if the RNA is of very poor quality
and so a couple years ago the scientists
at Illumina developed this new metric
that we call DD 200 that is allows us to
essentially quantify how much RNA is
worthy of making a library essentially
and what we found is that we can sort of
dose in the recommended input amount
based upon whether it's relatively high
quality RNA it could still be FFP but
it's relatively high quality where it's
greater than 70 percent
dv2 200 - really poor quality where you
have to put in even more than 100
nanograms if you if you usually don't
recommend it but actually some users
actually do take these really degraded
samples and put in 100 or 200 nanograms
to see what they can get you can see
that these samples are truly degraded
here based upon the the bioanalyzer
traces here or the fragment and at the
fragment analyzer traces that we're
showing here and so the way this this
works is a picture you have a fusion
event between two genes and you want to
capture that essentially what we have
done is designed probes against
sometimes only one of the genes would be
in our pool and the other gene might not
be in the pool which is shown here so we
have we have probes 80 more capture
probes shown here that are targeting
these green fragments what is
interesting and what makes this assay
really a nice discovery tool is that
even if the sort of gene over here gene
number two is not targeted we will still
capture fragments RNA fragments that
span that Junction essentially it's a
novel exon exon junction in these fusing
transcripts where you can pull this down
and by knowing what the green gene is
you can sequence across that RNA
fragment and essentially discover novel
partners even if you only know one of
the partners in the fusion event and so
you know for those of you who are
interested in this or study this you
know that in in many important fusion
events like those involving elk for
instance elk tends to form fusions with
many different partners we can find
those fusions using this assay even if
we don't know what gene two is and
that's what makes this really a powerful
approach this is some of the data where
we have used this and showing that we
can detect fusions in FFPE samples I
didn't mention this before but this this
assay is generally run on one eight
samples on the one mini C core my C crun
so that's what we're showing here these
are eight different samples that have
been multiplied
together on one my seek run and you can
see that we are detecting even in poorly
samples that have very high level of
degradation or low DB to hundreds we are
finding sort of the expected fusions
that we are looking for this is we've
developed some really nice software for
analyzing this we have a local run
manager lrm fusion module that if you
run this on mini seek or my seat you can
just analyze the data directly and get a
report like this where we will report
out high confidence Fusion calls or low
confidence Fusion calls or if you're
interested you can see all the fusions
that we looked for but didn't find in
the data so recurrent fusions that are
not called in your particular data so
this is a really nice report it tells
you the the the disease associated with
these fusions the actual gene gene
coordinates involved the number of reads
and sort of the confidence levels that
we have in the call this table kind of
gives you a little bit more details this
information is available on our website
so I'm not going to dwell on it I do
want to just say that we have a
companion panel that's quite a bit
larger 1385 genes it includes all the
500 in the fusion it also has more genes
that are involved in alternative
splicing and gene expression sort of
markers and cancer very similar
specifications you can see there's
obviously a lot more regions that are
targeted in this larger panel we
recommend to buy 76 base pair reads and
about 3 million reads to collect for
these samples so like I said if you're
interested in in in targeting RNA and
especially fusions these two side RNA
pan-cancer to site RNA fusion are really
nice new products that we put out in
last six months or so to do that and
there's much more information available
on our website the next sort of essay I
want to talk about is called true site
tumour 15 this is a completely different
approach this is basically a DNA
amplicon based focused
and so this is more like a PCR amplify
on a say it's much smaller in terms of
the targeting and much more focused on
multi gene cancer panel to cover these
seven types of diseases and we'll give
you readout on important mutations that
are involved in some of these diseases
you can see many of these are some of
the most famous and highly studied
cancer genes in in medicine today and
this panel is designed to give you a
really focused really high accuracy
readout and very sensitive readout of
all these genes this is the sort of
content and that the regions that are
targeted in specifically the mutations
that are targeted for this this just
shows a little bit about how the assay
works it's really a pretty
straightforward PCR assay where we leave
a little bit of an overhang and our
starting PCR primers that target the
gene specific regions and then we sort
of do a second cycle of PCR where we
include all the what we call the i5 and
i7 regions to create the adapters so
that this this construct here at the
bottom can be sequenced in our system so
we start with initial primers extension
primers so you end up with this
construct at the end of the process that
can be loaded onto ours any of our
sequencers this assay is is very
sensitive
it has about 250 amplicons in the sa
only requires 20 nanograms total we
actually split it into two ten nanogram
reactions to do the to do two different
pools it's eight sample throughput using
the mini seek or the my seek d3 and it
can call variant frequencies robustly
down to 5% some folks even push it below
that and when you're using this assay
under the under these conditions 93.5%
of the bases that we are targeting are
covered at greater than five
X coverage so you can get very deep
coverage on this which helps you to have
those low variant frequency calls this
just shows once again some of the the
data using this assay and FFPE sample
and you can see that this this shows the
the quality of the FFP a that was used
and you can see a very low quality FFP
we still get extremely nice coverage of
the percentage of bases that are at 500
X or higher and then sort of the mean
amplicon covered you can see is tens of
thousands for most of these samples and
so this is what allows you to get you
know extremely rare variant detection if
you're going to call below 5% or even at
5% and with good statistics you want to
have thousands of fold covered so that
you get mini reads that are so
representing the mutant allele so yeah
that just to remind me to say that these
actually if you if you're used to
measuring DNA Delta CQ using a PCR assay
to study the degradation of the DNA
these samples here are as low as Delta
CQ of four to six which is fairly
degraded FFP type samples this si is
also very accurate we we use some
standard samples to look at sort of
expected variance of these samples
versus the tested variants and you see
we get a almost a straight perfect
straight line between variants that are
all the way down to 5% all the way up to
above 50% and so this is this is all
done from FFP this is part of the sort
of validation work that we do when we
launch an assay like this this is
extremely high performing assay like I
say all the way down to 210 nanogram
pools of FFP material to get these
results and finally the last asset I
want to talk about is called to cite
tumor 170 it's it's an it's an
enrichment assay back to
so the first assay was a sort of an RNA
enrichment assay second assay was an
amplicon assay this assay is a is a DNA
based in Richmond assay it also has a
little trick where we could do RNA at
the same time and so this is much more
content than the previous assay up to
170 different genes and it's essentially
sort of a true seek library press hybrid
capture we also call minor allele
frequencies all the way down to 5% it
requires just 40 nano grams of DNA and
RNA then the neat thing about this
assays it can actually prep both the DNA
and RNA from your samples
we have very nice informatics suites
around this we have automation protocols
around this this prep as well and it
says they're coming towards the end of
2017 for custom solutions we have
launched this assay already this year so
this just shows some of the mutations
that you can detect with TST 17 170 and
in DNA you can detect single nucleotide
variants or or insertions and deletions
or amplification products or even phased
mutations where you have several
mutations all in the same in the same
area but on one strand and in the RNA
world we can detect gene fusions like
I've talked about already and then also
splice variants this panel is a much
larger panel than the TST 115 panel it
includes many more genes and a couple of
different diseases that are not
necessarily covered in in the TST 15
remember where we're targeting both DNA
and RNA that this panel and so some of
these assays are targeting known RNA
fusions which are really important for
certain diseases
this is kind of a a the types of this is
the gene list showing the types of
variants that we're looking for in the
sort of blue bubble here we are looking
for you know small variants single
nucleotide variants in this purple
bubble we're looking for RNA fusions and
splice variants and in this green bubble
we're looking for amplification of the
gene amplification as you can see a lot
of overlap some of these genes here in
the middle we actually are kind of
looking for all three things potentially
happening in those genes so they are the
assay like I said is unusual in that it
it will start with either fourteen
anagrams of FFP DNA or fourteen anagrams
of FFP RNA and go through a library step
process where you'll end up with a
library of DNA and RNA converted to cDNA
obviously and then at this point these
these are very similar in terms of their
ability to work in an enrichment
reaction so then we carry those library
products on into a capture based
enrichment where we use probes to pull
out all the information around those
genes and then we can analyze it on the
sequencing and we can tell based upon
the types of sequences we get whether
that came from DNA or RNA we can call
all the various mutations that we were
talking about on the previous line this
just shows the performance of TSP 170
that we can get really nice coverage
even with very low quality so this is a
this is a along the x-axis here is Delta
CQ where the higher you are here you are
starting to get really highly degraded
samples with Delta CQ of 6 7 8 on this
axis is the number of exons that we
target at 250x and you can see that it's
pretty much in the high 90s all the way
out to Delta CQ of 6 or so so that's
where we expect this assay out any gives
you some of the other suspects here at
the bottom of the slide but the point is
we get really nice results even with
highly degraded DNA
and this is some of the validation data
that we've generated using horizon
samples
these are very nice standard samples
that have a variance across this set
known and known levels which are shown
in green here and and then what you can
see is the what the assay reported in
blue and you can see there's a very good
concordance across all of these all of
these variants between what we expected
to see and what we actually measured or
quantified this is showing that we can
also detect amplifications between
different samples yet and even look at
variants in RNA structural variants in
terms of RNA fusions using RNA that has
very low quality and once again we're
using this DB 200 metric and so you know
we're able to to pick up copy number
variations for different regions
that are very clear using this assay so
this just shows some of the actually
beta testing data that we did during the
validation of this assay and so these
are three of the groups that worked with
us on this and you can see that they
detected for instance these variants
here we were we know these we expect to
see these in samples like the horizon
samples and they have an expected
variant frequency here and you can see
that all three of the users essentially
got excellent results and very nice
concordance even quantitative
concordance with the expected variations
across all the sites so this is a really
robust really accurate and quantitative
assay as I said we have the RNA aspect
to it where we can detect fusions and
that's what we're showing here these are
expected variants that were all detected
easily at all three of the sites using
using the TST 170 workflow and then this
is just showing that the the
measurements that we make also a very
high correlation with whole exome
sequencing and so the variant calls that
are called here are very so much what
you would get with whole exome
sequencing which is another type of
enrichment assay and so this makes a lot
of sense and finally this is a this is
information that once again more
detailed information on the on the true
site tumor 15 kit that we talked about
and the true site tumor 170 again these
this detailed information is available
at our website and if you're interested
at all and sort of targeted cancer
solutions I think these are these three
kits are should be of interest to you
so in conclusion I've tried to introduce
our new system which we think is going
to sort of really push the boundaries of
what people can do with next-generation
sequencing and then also three I think
of the more interesting new applications
that we have developed to study cancer
and and translational research in
particular the true site tumor 15
amplicon assay the to site tumor 170
enrichment assay that can enrich both
DNA and RNA and then also the the RNA
fusion assay which is really a much more
open-ended discovery tool for for
studying RNA fusions so that brings me
to the end of the presentation I'll just
remind you of our portfolio again from
the mini seek at the low end all the way
up to the new the new Novus six 6000 at
the very very high end really we have
sort of a variety of sequencers for a
variety of applications from human
genome sequencing and lots and lots of
on a Sikh and exomes up here down to
some of these targeted panels and
targeted solutions that we've been
talking about that run more on the neck
seek my seek and many seats
so with that I'd like to thank you for
your attention and once again I like to
thank lab roots for inviting me thank
you dr. shows for the informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
can I run different sequencing methods
in different lanes on Novus week using
the Lane loader device so that's a
that's a good question
so that Lane loader device is designed
to allow you to address any pool of
samples into the let's say on the s4
configuration there's four four lanes
that you can address so yes you could
you could put exomes let's say you want
to do exomes and RNA seek and microbial
genomes and human genomes you could you
could pull those all together and do all
the exomes in Lane one and all the RNA
seek in Lane two and the microbial
genomes in Lane three and and a handful
of human genomes in lane four so yes
that's that's possible with that Lane
loader device that's that's really one
of the main motivations for us putting
that into development
can the fusion kit detect novel RNA
fusions right so the the truesight
fusion kit that I talked about it
targets 507 genes and as I tried to show
in that diagram it can also target a
wider variety of genes if for instance
the the one half of the gene fusion is
something that we're probing for then we
should be able to pull down fragments
from the other side and capture
essentially novel novel transcripts or
novel fusion partners and so yes that's
kind of one of the most important
features of that assay is that it it can
easily detect all the genes that are
involved within the 500 set you know
sort of fusions between any of those 500
genes but you also have a very good
chance of capturing a fusion event
between any other gene in the human
genome and any of those 500 genes
great how well do the cancer panels work
on FFPE samples so all of the all of the
cancer panels that I talked about today
the TST 15 amplicon panel the true site
RNA fusion panel and the TST 170 cancer
panel they all work really well on FFPE
as I mentioned if you if you are
interested in you go to our website
Illumina calm and look under cancer you
can find a lot more specifications about
those kits but I believe they all are
they all work down in the same range of
twenty to forty nanograms of input of
either RNA or DNA - and that input
applies to FFP as well and so yes they'd
all three of those kits work really well
with FFP
okay for the next question we have does
index hopping occur on Nova's ich so
index hopping actually you know to some
degree occurs on across all of our
platforms and so yes it does occur on
Novus seek and we have I didn't have
time to get into that today we have been
developing a lot of new products and to
sort of addresses the index hoppy an
issue just to go through the information
on that we actually have a lot of
information about that on our website as
well we have a whole page dedicated to
index hopping if you're curious about
that but but I'll just kind of cover the
three main recommendations we have for
for index hopping is to first clean up
your libraries very well and remove any
free index adapters and primers we find
that is probably the biggest driver and
causing index hopping and the other
thing that we strongly recommend is to
use dual indexing and unique dual
indexing at that where you have actually
unique pairs of indexes on either side
of the fragment of interest so that if
you're using say a 16 Plex library pool
you have a set of indexes on each side
that is unique for all 16 fragments that
are in there 16 libraries that are in
the pool that allows you to do dual
indexing and it allows you to explicitly
identify any index hopping and eliminate
it from the data so that it is
completely not part of your analysis so
what we found is that index hopping does
does happen at very low levels much less
than 0.5 percent generally for for
almost all applications and that using
these two sort of preventative methods
where you actually basically make sure
you're having very clean libraries and
then design your experiment in a way
that you can use unique dual indexes
it's really not a concern for for all
applications these days and so if Nova
seek will be able to - you'll be able to
perform
these very highly multiplexed
experiments and Multan nova seek without
having to worry about index hopping
okay so the next question we have cannot
use custom primers on the no Bezique
system so that's a that's actually a
pretty easy question it's the short
answer is yes that the cartridges that
we use that your Porter's sampling
actually has a couple of open ports that
you can put in custom primers and and
you can easily program in the software
for to use those primers for various
products so if you have if you have
sample prep processes that you're used
to using that require custom primers or
if you're developing a new assay let's
say that you want to try out custom
primers that is possible to do on the
Nova system just like on many of our
other platforms
okay
it looks like we have time for one more
question what is the maximum read length
for a sequencing run so I assume that
that question is about the Nova seek
system the no basic system actually
allows up to two by 150 so 150 base pair
paired in reads if you remember the the
kit configurations that we are going to
offer with this system are 100 cycle 200
cycle and 300 cycle kids for at least
some of the flow cells and there's a
variety of configurations but
essentially with the 100 cycle kits you
could do actually single-ended 100 reads
or you could do paired in 55 50 or you
could do a 75 times a 25 they're
actually quite flexible with the 300
cycle kits you can go up to 150 so you
could do two by 150 with the 200 cycle
kits you could do 2 by 100 or you could
actually do a 150 and a 50 so there's
there's a lot of flexibility but on the
Nova 6 system as currently configured
the maximum read length in either read 1
or e 2 will be 150 base pairs
that was great
I would like to once again thank dr.
Schroeder for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible and
before we go and want to let everyone
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August of 2017 you will receive an email
from Lavery's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon goodbye